bonjour bonjour Comme vous pouvez le
constater ici c'est de la boue qui a
séché au revoir salut avant que cette
vidéo commence je dois vous parler du
sponsor de cette vidéo c'est la première
fois sur cette chaîne qu'une vidéo est
sponsorisée alors ce n'est pas un jeu
mobile ou des coques pour téléphone
c'est beaucoup mieux puisque c'est vous
suite à ma dernière vidéo vous avez été
nombreux et nombreuses à participer au
financement participatif sur mon utip et
je vous en suis infiniment
reconnaissante vous êtes donc les
sponsors de cette vidéo merci beaucoup
pour ce soutien et pour cette liberté je
vous laisse découvrir la suite bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo aujourd'hui je
me trouve dans la réserve naturelle des
gorges de Daluis aussi appelée petit
Colorado niçois et vous allez très vite
comprendre pourquoi je suis accompagnée
de Valentine de la chaîne sciences de
comptoir je vous invite fortement à
suivre et on va tout de suite rejoindre
Maxou
Maxime on va tout de suite rejoindre
Maxime qui va nous faire une petite
visite privée de la réserve c'est parti
on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc je m'appelle Maxime jugnier je suis
le garde animateur naturaliste de la
Réserve Naturelle Régionale des gorges
de daluisse ça se trouve dans les
Alpes-Maritimes exactement dans
l'arrière-pays niçois
dans cette vidéo vous apercevrez aussi
Coline qui est stagiaire au moment du
tournage
j'espère que vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon ami je l'ai appelé Bernard
venez on va voir les cailloux
du coup là on peut le voir on a de la
pélite qui est présente ici c'est une
roche qui s'est déposée il y a 300
millions d'années et c'est une lune est
plus vieilles roches qu'on peut il se
connaitre dans le secteur et elle est
rouge parce que c'est oxydée avec le fer
le fer qui est du coup dedans dans cette
dans cette playlist et là on peut le
voir on est vraiment au cœur de la
réserve au cœur de la pelite rouge et
c'est super beau quoi
c'est vrai que c'est plutôt pas mal
sur cette plaque d'argile qu'on avait il
y a 300 millions d'années on a une pluie
intense type tropicale qui est tombé sur
cette plaque qui a permis de faire du
coup les traces de gouttes de pluie
qu'on voit ici et la pluie c'est
interrompue d'un coup ce qui n'a pas
permis le déclaivage ensuite de l'argile
donc c'est pour ça que on a le reste de
ses petits fossiles de gouttes de pluie
qui sont restés un avis sur cette
explication j'ai trouvé ça merveilleux
merveilleux
[Applaudissements]
et des petites gouttes de pluie
fossilisées et vas-y que ça fait des
petits boudins de je sais pas quoi je
veux genre ça m'intéresse ah ouais c'est
joli
[Musique]
ici on est vraiment à la confiance entre
deux climats à la fois le militaire
année et l'alpan le climat méditerranéen
c'est vraiment sur lequel on est les
caractérisé notamment par un gradient
qui est assez fort donc ici on a environ
à 700 mètres d'altitude donc purement
méditerranéen il y a juste derrière dans
les hauteurs on arrive tout de suite à
1800 mètres d'altitude on va rencontrer
vraiment un climat alpin et donc une
fois on a une fleur qui va s'exprimer en
climat plutôt montagnard par exemple en
haut de la réserve on a du mélèze et ici
on va plutôt être sur des Landes à
pellites donc des Landes des des garrix
si on veut qu'on croise partout en
Méditerranée cette flore assez vraiment
adaptée à la sécheresse au sol qui est
assez pauvre finalement sur la pilite
qui est peu profond donc par exemple sur
la réserve on peut croiser beaucoup plus
d'espèces aromatiques donc comme le thym
le romarin la sarriette et aussi des des
plantes qui sont plutôt grasses qui vont
stocker de l'eau justement parce qu'avec
les épisodes de sé et qui sont de plus
en plus intenses elles ont eu cette
particularité de pouvoir stocker de
l'eau dans leur feuille pour pouvoir les
distribuer donc tout au long de l'année
et ne pas mourir
[Applaudissements]
alors une réserve naturelle il y a deux
types il y a les nationales et il y a
les régionales nous aussi on est sur une
Réserve naturelle régionale qui permet
de protéger une entité que ce soit pour
sa biodiversité mais aussi pour ça
géologie et on va aussi parler du
patrimoine culturel sur les raisins
naturels et donc il y a trois missions
principales on est réserves naturelles
c'est protéger gérer et sensibiliser le
protéger ça passe par l'application de
la réglementation d'une réserve
naturelle
[Musique]
on sort pas des sentiers
tu diras à ton papa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'on a parlé de se baigner en
fait
[Musique]
gérer ça a plutôt passé par de la
conciliation d'acteurs il serait
vraiment en constante évolution avec les
acteurs essayer de développer les
projets sur ce territoire parce que
c'est vraiment un outil de territoire
une réserve naturelle et enfin on a le
côté sensibilisation où là on accompagne
les scolaires les collégiens le grand
public sur des animations pour les
sensibiliser à l'environnement
[Applaudissements]
comme animaux on a une autre spécificité
sur la réserve c'est le maillot de la
pélite qui est une espèce endémique donc
au monde elle est présente que dans les
gorges d'aluzz ainsi que les gorges du
science et on ne peut le voir sur cette
petite paroi donc on va le maillot de la
pellite qui est tout petit escargot donc
c'est un petit mollusque un peu plus
petit escargot qui est la même couleur
que la roche donc lui c'est vraiment
adapté à son support il est devenu rouge
comme la pilite pour pouvoir bien se
confondre dans cette roche cette
escargot là il va souvent être rétracté
dans cette petite interstices de roche
pour pouvoir être à l'abri donc du
soleil pour pouvoir justement supporter
cette cette chaleur méditerranéenne mais
on a aussi une deuxième espèce qui est
endémique des gorges d'alwis et du cyan
qui est le marbrerie de la pélite donc
c'est un autre escargot qui est se
confond beaucoup avec l'escargot de Nice
qui est beaucoup plus rare à l'échelle
de la réserve il se confondu aussi à la
à la pilote à l'API donc elles sont
supports
[Musique]
dis-nous Valentine en face de nous il y
a des roches rouges en bas et des roches
blanches grises en haut oui comment cela
se fait style et bien c'est la magie
j'ai dit fesses parce qu'en fait voiture
à ce niveau là en fait le contact entre
les deux c'est le contact entre l'air
primaire et leur secondaire leur
secondaire c'est quand à deux fuseaux
horaires notamment et ce contact c'était
une extinction de masse la plus grosse
qu'on est connue c'est la mère de toutes
les extinctions on l'appelle des fois
c'est l'extinction permet un Trias cette
crise là ça a entraîné la mort de 95%
des espèces marines et 70% des espèces
terrestres les plantes ont pris méga
cher et du coup ça s'est répercuté sur
toute la chaîne alimentaire et la vie a
eu ami je recommençais
tu couperas et la vie a mis beaucoup
beaucoup de temps à se à se remettre de
cette extinction on se demande pourquoi
et voilà et c'est beau on admire la mort
là c'est fou
non mais c'est assez impressionnant à
voir et ce qui est marrant c'est qu'il y
avait plein plein d'espèces donc pour au
moment où ce sont déposés toutes ces
pélites il y a très très peu de faux
cils là-dedans par contre ça a retenu
genre des des traces de gouttes de pluie
genre une averse c'est bon on a des
averses de genre 300 millions d'années
qui ont survécu ici et ça je trouve ça
ouf c'est dingue on le voit on marche
dessus c'est pas ça qu'on appelle des
maîtres kraks non les modes crack c'est
des craquelures de boue donc c'est genre
quand tu as comme dans le Roi Lion oui
tu as donc ça pleut très fort et puis
après grosse grosse sécheresse et du
coup ça te fait plein de fissures des
trucs comme ça et ben voilà et ça ça
donne il y en a partout ici c'est
incroyable au monde c'est vrai ouais
c'est trop cool
ta vie
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu peux parler des suivis
scientifiques que vous faites dans la
réserve donc on a différents
on s'intéresse notamment à nos
endémiques forcément des escargots on
fait des suivis principes un peu
l'évolution des populations sur la
réserve on va s'intéresser au mammifère
où là on pose des pièges photographiques
sur le site notamment pour suivre le
loup mais on ça nous permet de suivre
les autres espèces notamment les serres
les renards ou les jeunettes et oui
après je peux continuer en parlant des
insectes où on fait des suivis
scientifiques sur les papillons de la
réserve où on a plusieurs espèces qui
sont protégés également on fait des
suivis sur les cirques aussi depuis
quelques temps
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il y a des menaces qui passent
sur
grosse pression qui pèse sur la réserve
c'est notamment liée au réchauffement
climatique là depuis un an à peu près on
travaille sur la réserve à établir un
plan d'adaptation climatique où on
essaie de comprendre comment va évoluer
la réserve et donc de trouver des
solutions concrètes pour essayer
d'endiguer cette ce réchauffement
climatique sur le site
alors du coup ça se présente assez mal
si on suit les projections du GIEC où on
va avoir une colonisation beaucoup plus
sèche donc de la garrigue sur les
secteurs alpins et donc la toute a
disparition de la faune plutôt liée au
climat montagnard et avec une plutôt une
colonisation des de la faune lié au
climat méditerranéen
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire à notre
échelle vous pouvez vous engager un peu
au niveau politique pour déjà dire vos
idées et moi un petit échelle mais
d'essayer de porter votre voix pour
arrêter certains projets qui peuvent
porter atteinte un environnement merci
beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
connaissez-vous cet endroit
connaissez-vous cette personne bonjour
je vous invite fortement à aller suivre
Valentine sur sa chaîne qui s'appelle
sciences de comptoir qui parle de
géologie de cailloux mais pas que est-ce
que tu veux nous dire un peu ce que tu
fais sur ta chaîne de la merde bonjour
voilà voilà l'univers de Valentine
allez-y c'est très intéressant c'est
très drôle et on se retrouve très vite
sur le terrain pour une prochaine vidéo
peut-être pas avec cette personne ah
elle vient vraiment de me lécher la main
coucou papa
casse-toi d'accord
[Rires]
3 2 1 et Pépé on sort pas des sentiers
non non non
[Rires]
on sort pas des sentiers
oh là là on est meilleurs amis regardez
ça là
c'est bon la maladie
on est trop près je trouve
comment un caillou ah oui